American people need champions to remind
them what they're capable of just you're
the best
the fastest man on earth
who do we have here I'm Jesse Owens
you're a natural
I don't trust naturals I will say you
can run oil boy you can join me what I
want to know is can you win say we got
here
hi Palm Coast I know you want me to do
it again yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
you want to win a golden medal show come
on do it in Berlin mr. Owens how can you
justify taking part in Germany when
there's so much discrimination here at
home now what you boys think you're
going just using the showers not until
we're through you're not just you have a
chance to strike a powerful blow under
the Hitler regime we must not go to
these Olympic Games to show our
solidarity with the oppressed people of
Germany you'll get a chance to be a part
of history and you're gonna walk away
from it I've got people looking at me
funny yeah well you're white Larry you
don't have to people are counting on you
to do what you're not over there to
Berlin and beat those Nazis he was put
here to fight
don't listen to any of them
I there ain't no black and white there's
only Fast and Slow nothing matters not
color not money not even for those 10
seconds you are completely free now he's
just showing off